Pancreatic cancer is the third leading cause
of cancer related death in the US and is predicted
to become the second leading cause of cancer
mortality by 2020.
Despite recent advances, the 5-year survival
rate remains less than 7%.
The majority of patients present with advanced
stage disease, and available treatments with
FOLFIRINOX or nab-paclitaxel plus gemcitabine
chemotherapy provide only modest survival
benefit.
In addition, patients who undergo attempts
at curative surgery plus adjuvant chemotherapy
still have a very poor 5-year survival rate
at roughly 15-20% with 80% of patients relapsing
after resection.
These poor outcomes highlight the need for
novel development of biomarkers to predict
patient survival and treatment response with
potential linkage to different therapeutic
options.
In general, the term “pancreatic cancer”
encompasses a mix of pathologies in which
the cells originate in the pancreas and are
thought to be epithelial in origin; however,
the question of the cellular origin of the
disease continues to be debated.
Even with access to modern-day molecular profiling,
histology that distinguishes the exact pathologic
subtype of pancreatic lesions is still the
most clinically informative piece of data.
Exocrine pancreatic cancers can have a gland-like
appearance and are the most common types of
pancreatic cancer; the majority are classified
as pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma, commonly
referred to as PDAC or PDA.
Other forms of exocrine cancers are rare but
are typically cystic or can be acinar cell
carcinomas.
Endocrine cancers are a small subset of all
pancreatic cancers.
Pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors are classified
as functional hormone-producing or nonfunctional
non–hormone-producing.
While histologic features are still used to
define and diagnose pancreatic cancer subtypes,
more recently, modern molecular techniques
such as next-generation DNA sequencing and
RNA sequencing have been used to further classify
pancreatic cancer subtypes.
The hope is to discover better targets and
improve the therapeutic options.
Several studies have examined gene expression
using microarrays or RNA sequencing and have
identified distinct RNA signatures of PDAC.
Collisson et al originally described 3 PDAC
gene expression subtypes, including classical,
quasi mesenchymal, and exocrine-like subtypes.
Moffitt et al later used a “virtual microdissection”
approach on data from primary and metastatic
PDAC tumors to digitally separate tumor, stromal,
and normal cell gene expression.
They identified 2 tumor-specific signatures,
including a classical subtype and a basal-like
gene expression program that resembled the
basal subtype of breast and bladder cancers.
Moreover, they also identified 2 stroma-specific
gene expression signatures and demonstrated
that combinations of the stroma and tumor-specific
subtypes represent distinct biology with different
prognostic implications.
The International Cancer Genome Consortium
subsequently defined 4 major gene expression
subtypes of PDAC, including a pancreatic progenitor
class that showed strong overlap with the
Collisson and Moffitt classical subtypes,
as well as a squamous classification that
closely resembles the Moffitt basal-like subtype.
Additionally, the International Cancer Genome
Consortium study also described an aberrantly
differentiated endocrine exocrine subtype
and a novel immunogenic subtype that was associated
with evidence of a significant immune infiltration.
These classifications are more similar than
different, and several common themes have
emerged.
The classical or pancreatic progenitor and
the basal-like or squamous neoplastic subtypes
have been validated across multiple studies
in primary and metastatic samples.
Basal-like or squamous tumors harbor a significantly
worse prognosis than classical or progenitor
tumors.
These basal-like or squamous tumors also display
more frequent TP53 mutations, a higher pathologic
grade, and a poorer response to modern chemotherapy
regimens.
Recently, the Cancer Genome Atlas project
provided further data suggesting that the
pancreatic progenitor or squamous subtype
was independent of purity.
In contrast, the ADEX or immunogenic subtype
have lower tumor purity.
The study also found that, among low-purity
tumors, a higher estimated leukocyte fraction
was associated with immunogenic samples.
Considering only the high-purity samples in
the cohort, the squamous samples of Bailey
et al. showed significant overlap with the
basal-like samples defined by Moffitt et al.,
while the Bailey et al. pancreatic progenitor
and Collisson et al. classical group largely
overlapped the classical samples defined by
Moffitt et al.
These observations suggest that high-purity
tumors can be consistently classified into
a basal-like/squamous group and a classical/progenitor
group.
The strong association of immunogenic and
ADEX or exocrine-like subtypes with the low-purity
samples in the cohort suggests that these
subtypes may reflect gene expression from
nonneoplastic cells.
In summary, cross-comparison of the studies
does demonstrate that reproducible biologic
subgroups are emerging in pancreatic cancer.
While the nomenclature differs, there are
strong biological similarities between the
classical (Collisson and Moffitt), stable
(Waddell), and pancreatic progenitor (Bailey)
subtypes.
Likewise, the quasi-mesenchymal (Collisson),
unstable (Waddell), squamous (Bailey), and
basal-like (Moffitt) subtypes are biologically
similar.
Finally, the exocrine-like (Collisson) and
ADEX (Bailey) subtypes have overlapping characteristics.
Nevertheless, a critical question is whether
these subgroups offer more prognostic or predictive
clinical information about pancreatic cancer
than conventional pathology information.
Indeed, comparisons of the defined subtypes
suggest some prognostic relevance.
In particular, the prognosis of the quasi-mesenchymal/squamous/basal-like
subtype is worse than that of the classical/pancreatic
progenitor subtype.
Furthermore, there is the question of whether
patients with certain subtypes of pancreatic
cancer are more appropriate candidates for
novel therapies.
For example, Bailey et al inferred that the
immunogenic subgroup will be more responsive
to immunotherapies.
Their reasoning is biologically sound, but
given the recent history of a lack of benefit
from immunotherapies in pancreatic cancer,
this hypothesis, too, must be thoroughly tested
in clinical trials, or at least by retrospective
analyses.
Other relevant questions remain that may be
obstacles in moving this subtyping to the
clinic include, 1) Can subtypes change within
a tumor, i.e. how can we address intratumoral
heterogeneity?
Can exposure to therapy change the subtype
of a tumor?
Can we design novel targeted drugs that can
benefit all subtypes?
Additionally, a byproduct of these deep genetic
analyses will inevitably be to identify distinct,
targetable molecular abnormalities; in order
to benefit an individual patient, however,
these abnormalities will need to be identified
by real-time methods.